throughout the film hazel is reading
this book an imperial infliction where
she's wondering what's going to happen
to anna's family at the end of the book
are you wondering what's going to happen
to hazel's family after the film
you know we had a lot of questions about
that we talked about that and wondered
about it as actors myself and sam
trammell who played the dad and
you know the beauty of the question is
um
how deeply we care for each other and
instead of being locked in your own pain
you're considering the other person's
experience
whether it's in heartbreak uh or in in
deeper forms of loss
it's a beautiful thing that people are
considering each other and especially a
teenage girl i find that so moving
so yeah you mentioned the teenage girl
you're obviously playing shaylee
muddly's mum how how was it filming
those kind of mother daughter scenes
fantastic she's my girlfriend and that's
what john green wrote you know he wrote
two peers uh with mutual respect and
admiration for each other and that's a
rare mother-daughter relationship to see
or you know read and so i felt really
lucky to play that why is it important
to you then to make this film
because i am trying to figure out every
day how to remain grateful
it's quite elusive it's easy to have it
for a moment and then
you know be bummed out over whatever
life is dealing you on a given day and
so to stay true to gratitude and loving
deeply and appreciating all that we're
given is uh is a great lesson to learn
and john green's done it in a very
clever
and irreverent way and
that's why i feel like the film is for
every age male female it's a really
important movie i think just finally
then this film was obviously massive in
america it's gonna be massive over here
as well it's not the first massive film
you've been a part of obviously you're
in jurassic park have you got any
thoughts on the new um film they're
making jurassic world excited for that
i'm very excited i'm very curious to see
it and
you know was so thrilled to be part of a
couple of them and
also thrilled to not be chased by
dinosaurs in this movie
i'm tired